it's a rare thing to have a film that's
been
you know we shot three years ago
and still hasn't come out yet well
that's one thing i was excited about
with this role is it was kind of
perfectly tailored for for me and the
things that i'm fascinated with as far
as it comes with acting i'm excited it's
time for it to come out and i think it's
the right time
hey i'm jared leto and this is how i
became dr michael morbius
yeah when i got the role i i was
fortunate because there's so much
material there's so the the character
has been interpreted interpreted by many
writers before in the comics so i was
just inundated i was buried in
in comics and that was great i i read as
much as i could
uh and just educated myself about this
character
and uh and all the stories and the
artwork of course is a big influence
sometimes you can just look at a drawing
and get inspired
and it can stoke your imagination so
some of my favorite was from from the
70s uh there was just kind of really
elaborate
uh detailed drawings that were just so
beautifully done those those inspired me
i started at the beginning with the
beautiful source material and just that
that was the launch pad well i've always
loved vampires too when i was a little
kid one of the first movies i ever saw
was the original dracula black and white
was with my grandmother i remember i was
up late at night couldn't sleep and she
let me watch it with her and on the
television and i love the you know lost
boys interview with the vampire i love
the hunger with david bowie there's so
many great uh gary oldman was incredible
and dracula uh but there's something
classic about it is our archetypal about
it that that we keep revisiting for a
reason it's part of our culture there's
there's a mythology there i think we're
drawn to
that kind of battle between good and
evil between our our our primal impulses
um and it's just a fascinating a
fascinating one
i was trying to help people
but the cure
it's curse
the thing that i was really excited
about is i had the opportunity to bring
this character to life for the very
first time on the big screen
i mean a pretty big honor uh it's rare
that
you have the opportunity to do this in
the marvel world because so many of
these characters have been portrayed
already so
that was pretty a big responsibility you
know i buried myself in everything that
i could i dove as deep as i could i
i
did all the research and then you have
to let your imagination take over and it
was my job to interpret this character
uh uh in this way in a new way and i
really had a lot of fun with it the
challenge was there were really three
three roles in one a frail dr michael
morbius when we meet him he's at the
the end of his life he's really fighting
just to stay alive and to find a cure
for this really rare disease and then we
see him when he's strong and healthy
and then ultimately when he's monstrous
so uh that that was the big challenge
here is juggling those three
and
you know and i loved it all our lives
we've lived with death why shouldn't
they know what it feels like for a
change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
i've done such
a variety roles
someone was saying the other day i've
imagined putting them all in the same
room and the conversation that would
happen
is just nuts you know and uh even from
just paulo gucci to we crash to morbius
the little things to joker it's all it's
all so different i like that i like to
to find differences rather than
similarities look being sick and frail
and that physical component was really
challenging it's also a kind of a dark
place to be and
but i had this beautiful experience
working with people that
have rare diseases and i you know they
they educated me and informed me and
helped me with with so much but but the
hardest part was probably when dr
michael morbius is healthy and seemingly
kind of normal you know to play a
character close to me you know i'm not
saying i'm normal but uh but playing a
character close to to me was actually
something i've done the least
um so that was that was uh that was hard
that was challenging you know to use
mike a voice that's really close to my
own was really unique yeah it's that
kind of role where you have a lot of
surprises and there are a lot of
challenges you know there's a lot of
fighting in the film as well and
you know we had just an incredible
group of stunt people and
and fight coordinators and
you know they they are just you know the
unsung heroes of projects like these
they they do things that are just
you know miraculous and to be honest
pretty insane you know there there's
movie magic at play sometimes there's
rehearsal and hard work and practice at
play
but you know though those
i'm always quick to let those people
jump in and do their job you know
because that's what they train for
that's what they live for and i i love
to share that the experience with with
those people
who the hell are you matt i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service yeah i think
you know it's hard to play good some
people are just are great at that but as
an actor to be someone who's so good all
the time you know that's not that's not
that's not how we are you know we're
imperfect we make mistakes and um i i
don't know i think it's fascinating to
look take a look at that a choice
between that that delicate
line that line of conflict between good
and evil and not being able to say no to
that
impulse
is is something we look at in this film
quite a bit
it would be incredible to
get in the ring with some of these
phenomenal actors like michael keaton
again and
tom hardy and
you know
tom holland
that would be that would be a dream come
true
so morbius is a new beginning it's a
it's a character on screen for the very
first time
it's um in theaters april 1st
uh as we're coming out of this crazy
coveted world
hopefully
and
i think it's a perfect time to celebrate
a big fun popcorn movie like this and
who knows maybe maybe we'll be back
you